hi this is david byrne this is the wired
auto complete interview
[Music]
why when
where and how those are the questions
we'll be answering today
did david byrne start the talking heads
i don't know if i could take full credit
for that i think it might have been the
drummer chris france who might have said
hey
you've got some songs why don't we uh
you know
rehearse and learn them and practice
them up do you remember how the name
came was there other names in contention
yeah there was lots of other names a
friend of ours was staying crashing at
our loft and we had lists of band names
so and he added to the submission and i
think it came from like a b movie that
was on late night tv
did david byrne make music with david
bowie not to my knowledge
did david burns sing on you can call me
al not on the recording but i did
uh do a performance of it and paul simon
watched me from the wings
it was just a little bit tough
how many how am i doing paul how am i
doing did david byrne design bike racks
yes he did he's done different kinds
some for specific neighborhoods in new
york and some
uh for
the i guess what's called the brooklyn
arts district you can reconfigure them
to make different words
and
why did david byrne start acting i have
no ambition to be an actor i honestly
don't think i'm that good at it and
there are people who are really really
good at it occasionally when a
movie director friend or someone like
that would say
david will you just
do this it's really easy or
has happened in one case we
yes uh i want you to be in this movie
but just play yourself so i said okay
i'll give it a try but you know i have
no ambitions here so
if it doesn't work out you can fire me
why is david byrne in a tutu years ago
we played a show at radio city and we
couldn't get the rockettes it was like
just incredibly expensive and
so we all decided okay let's all put on
two twos for the last number and we'll
try and figure out how to
do some kind of chorus line thing why is
his play called american utopia it's
also the name of uh
the album the last album i did and it
was not meant facetiously or ironically
it was meant to i sense that
some of what i was doing on stage and
what the band was doing and what the
songs were saying
we're talking about this kind of
yearning that we all have
to try and discover
how to make a better life how to make a
better life lives for all of us and so i
thought
i want to kind of follow that i want to
kind of be
be sincere about that and see if we can
represent some of that hope and
possibility on stage why isn't david
byrne reuniting the talking heads in a
nutshell i think i could say that
we we came together
more as friends than as
you know
incredible musicians it was really kind
of a shared musical taste and then
gradually
as you grow as you age and you grow and
explore
your musical tastes start to change it
became more of a kind of a work that we
did we didn't all hang out all the time
anymore so eventually kind of you just
kind of drift apart that way
here we go what was david burns first
hit it kind of depends
the first really big one was uh burning
down the house but then we did pretty
good with uh take me to the river before
that once in a lifetime which is pretty
popular surprisingly was not hardly
played on the radio when it came out at
all it was considered too funky for rock
radio what is david burns most played
song i have absolutely no idea i know
that uh this must be the place
gets played at a lot of weddings
people get married to that song one time
when we played vegas
a band member and i
biked by a drive-through church and we
said can we hire the minister to do a
wedding
um during our show and so i offered to
marry people during the show and i would
sing this song to them next one what did
david byrne won an oscar win an oscar
for
um
not for grammar i want an oscar for uh
co-writing the soundtrack to a movie
called the last emperor what songs make
david byrne cry i have a monthly
playlist that i post and
one of them was just songs that make me
cry and there's a lot there's a couple
hours worth at least one that i remember
off the top of my head is a nico case
song
called
honolulu and then i think it's the date
and it's a song of her witnessing
a mother yelling at her child
and
telling her child get away from me
why can't you ever do anything right
that kind of stuff where it's just like
you it just rips you apart
because you're in her shoes
witnessing this
yeah what does david burn dance like
that's a matter of
opinion so at some point i realized
i was not able
to do all the steps that i was seeing
other people doing and i also decided
that why should i bother learning that
because they've got that down that
perfectly and that's their thing i need
to come up with my own thing and so
gradually little by little i adopted
some moves that felt comfortable to me
it's like that
with that adage you know dance like
nobody's watching which is kind of what
i do and and sometimes
people do watch because it then it's
like
what's he doing okay we're gonna go to
the next one
where did david burn get his start i was
in a band with some friends at um
at art school in providence rhode island
really just for fun we didn't take it
seriously it wasn't like a career move
and then we came to new york and
auditioned to play at a club called
cbgb's which is a
was initially meant to be a bluegrass
club and we passed the audition
we got a gig there was no big plan it
was just kind of oh let's write some
songs and play them and
uh see if anybody likes it and a few
people did and then the next time we
played a few more people came and it
seemed to take off eventually it was
slow which was kind of good learned to
be a little
tighter and less sloppy and
all that where is david burns big suit
uh you know i don't know exactly might
have been at the rock and roll hall of
fame in cleveland
or it might be in storage somewhere or
it might be out going on a tour by
itself i'm not sure do you know what
size that would constitute how many x's
in front of that xl
no idea
uh it was important to me that the the
big suit not look like a fat suit
uh but that it looked like more like a
playing card
uh you know kind of flat but wide and
rectangular where does david burn record
his music these days i often record the
beginnings of songs or music or whatever
at home
and then eventually when it gets to a
certain point i move to a proper
recording studio and bring in other
musicians and all that but that's
kind of a luxury that we we have now
that we can take our time if we don't
like something
there's no embarrassment of saying oh
that didn't work you just
come in the next morning and go i'm
going to wipe that there's little less
less pressure but it's still yeah you do
have to have a work ethic to keep at it
where is david brown right now where am
i right now i'm
uh
in the conde nast building 20 something
floor
okay
thank you who introduced david byrne to
music it would be my parents scottish
folk music mozart i didn't really adopt
any of those but
pete seeger they played pete seeger who
is david byrne collaborating with i
recently did a song with
a an australian artist named montane she
approached me about
doing a song here and we ended up doing
two songs together and i think they came
out really good and i did a song uh for
a movie with uh
the artist named mitsky i did a
collaboration with yola tengo in uh
that was something that ben gibbard uh
suggested was he was putting together
a collection of songs by yoko ono i
picked a
a really old one that's really pretty
who samples david byrne psycho killer
this is selena gomez song that has uh
he's just kind of the bass line from
psycho keller
that was and it's a good song too bad
liar i think that might be the name of
it something like that
who inspires david byrne well quite a
few people there's a group out of uh i
think the west coast called gabriel's
that i
listened to the other day i thought that
was really good i'm friends with a
brazilian musician katana veloso
he's always an inspiration because i
never know what he's going to do next
the best inspiration is when
you don't try and imitate them but it
inspires you you to be more of
yourself to express yourself and find
your own way of of expressing things who
does david byrne look like one time at
new orleans jazz fest when i was younger
i was in line getting some
gumbo or something like that and a young
man came up to me and said i know who
you are i know who you are
you're norman bates and i thought not
only
does he think
i'm a fictional character
but it's
a psycho killer well i couldn't there
was not much more i could say about that
thank you
how does music work david byrne i wrote
a book by that name and i
attempt to
explore how all these extra musical
contexts and factors uh shape the music
that we hear
it might be financial stuff that makes
how you know what kind of music you can
produce and record it might be the
acoustics of the various rooms that
music is performed in that kind of
shapes what kind of music is
heard best in those rooms and so i yeah
i explored all those kinds of things how
does he write songs i write songs in
lots of different ways i sometimes start
with words if there's a story if i've
written musicals then you definitely
have to start with the words first and
other times you know i've got a great
musical idea a nice melody and i will
try and find words that fit that which
is sometimes a little bit
uh of a longer process but that can work
as well you look back on your early
writing do you see yourself as a
different writer now yes i i think i
write different things now than i would
that i did then in the past occasionally
i
find some scraps of paper with old
lyrics on some of them are still useful
but i real
useful because i look at them and i go
i'd never write that today how does he
know saint vincent we both did a concert
at radio city as a benefit it was called
how dark was the night i think i'd seen
her live at bowery ballroom and
went up to her and said i saw your show
and i thought it was really good i
really liked your record um
that's when we met we crossed paths
again and
someone asked us if we would do a
collaboration together which we did how
many songs does david byrne have i
haven't kept track i don't write songs
every day
um i sort of go through intense periods
of writing songs and other periods when
i'm
doing something completely different
and now
all right that's it next time let's have
something a little more uh metaphysical
maybe a little more philosophical
you know
something with a little more weighty
i mean
this is the kind of you can find out on
google
[Music]